Good morning. Hank, it's Friday.
It's actually morning for once, hence the coffee.
I love it when the coffee's done.
I have a letter for your 15 year-old self today.
But first, in your video on Wednesday, you talked about lexical gaps,
like the fact that in Romanian, there is no word for shallow,
and in English, we don't have a word for people who aren't virgins.
Turns out, by the way, that there IS a word in Romanian for people who aren't virgins.
But anyway, it seemed to me that we need to plug that lexical gap and then plug it again and ag-
Sorry. It was jokes like that that won me a Printz Award.
Anyway, Hank, as you pointed out on Twitter,
the best antonym for virgin suggested in comments by far was...virg-out.
But Hank what the non-virgin lexical gap really made me think was,
that, like, our obsession with sexual purity is such that once you are no longer this thing you are...indescribable.
Which is exactly what I want to talk to your 15 year-old self about.  That won't be awkward...
But first, also in Wednesday's video, you said:
"Also, dump your girlfriend.
I don't know who your girlfriend is, I don't know how much you like her, but dump her right now."
I'm calling Fran, my girlfriend from when I was 15.
[Hi, you've reached Fran. I'm sorry I missed your call...]
Dahhh...
She called back!
Hello?
[Hello?]
Hi, Fran!
[Hi, John Green.]
He made a video saying that I should dump whoever I was dating when I was 15, which was you.
[True. That's true.]
So...uhhh...
[Are you breaking up with me?]
This is gonna be awkward for both of us.
Uh...because we're both married.
[True.]
But I don't think it's gonna work out.
[No? Is it something I said?]
Uhh, I mean, it's partly like, you not being attracted to people of  my gender.
[Oh my god, that's so true. That's true.]
[Do you think we could still be friends?]
(laughter)
I think we could still be friends. You're always so nice about everything that's going on in Nerdfighteria.
It's very...I always notice when you, like, retweet me
and stuff. It's really nice of you.
[I'm a big fan of Nerdfighteria.
I feel like I am a Nerdfighter.]
Well, she seemed devastated.
Here's what I want to say, 15-year old Hank:
It's not that big of a deal.
Sexuality is important,
but it's certainly not the only interesting or important thing happening to you right now.
15 year-old Hank, both you and I live in a world that tells us that there are only two important things.
One is the acquisition of goods, and the other is either the acquisition or avoidance of sex.
But Hank, it turns out that the question of who's a virgin and who's a virg-out is not the most interesting question.
And the romantic relationships in your life are not the only important relationships.
As I give this advice, I realize that it is not intended for 15 year-old Hank. It is intended for 15 year-old John.
15 year-old Hank, you're doing great.
And if you're watching this, the only thing you're probably thinking is, "Is that a My Little Pony in the background?"
Yes, yes it is.
15 year-old Hank, check this out!
In the future, you're going to write songs, and people are going to paint ponies about your songs.
Which your brother will then steal.
Some things never change.
Hank, I'll see you on Monday.